part of my review of jack ryan shadow
recruit i said a safe bet is an
international spy movie because it is
you know it's not a safe bet buddy cop
movie it's not the same ride alongs so
right along is a buddy cop movie with
one cop and a guy who's trying to
impress him he's not actually a cop it's
not really a buddy cop movie it stars
Ice Cube is this hardcore cop who's the
brother of this one chick who's way too
hot for someone like Kevin Hart in this
movie in particular it again and Kevin
Hart's dating her and he wants to
impress Ice Cube so Ice Cube's like you
know what you're coming on a ride-along
with me man you can impress me now we
have our buddy cop movie with one cop
it's still a buddy cop movie though guys
know how I feel about buddy cop movies
they have to really impress me movie to
be fair Kevin Hart carried this entire
movie he was the most energetic he was
the funny one I know he's supposed to be
the funny one I'm just saying he was the
entertaining one you can still be
entertained in the movie without the
movie being funny without the funny guy
doing funny guy things but any form of
entertainment whatsoever in this movie
had to do with Kevin Hart al-habib I
isn't saying that because I think Kevin
Hart's hilarious new just really cracks
me up and he cracked me up in the movie
it looks like Kevin Hart ad-libbed a lot
of things in the movie and you know
props to him for doing that but the duo
of him and Ice Cube working together I
feel like Ice Cube could have been
played by anybody he could have been the
rock he could have been Bruce Willis he
could have been samuel l.jackson or any
other hardcore cop who's like this
brother figure that you want to impress
but all in all it's a series of
scenarios the funniest of which were in
the trailer shooting range scene the
funniest scene in the movie all the
funny scenes in the shooting range scene
you saw in the trailer so that
compromises the experience a bit I did
the thing I don't like doing in movies
in this movie as I started checking my
watch and I was like how long is this
movie when you start wishing and hoping
that the movie just wraps up and ends
well that's not good speaking of my jack
ryan shadow recruit review I said it's
an average spy movie but you know by
definition it's not necessarily the
biggest negative ever if you go to
someone you're like that's an average
spy movie they'll be like alright so is
entertaining enough right they know
there's a level of entertainment in
there you got someone you're like that's
your average buddy cop movie they're
just like I'm sorry to hear that they
know it's a negative because they know
you're saying it's a cliche premise with
at least one of the two characters in
the movie who could have been swapped
out by a lot of other people
the movie seemed unbalanced I feel like
Kevin Hart carried the entire movie for
so long he had to have been like come on
guys I can't do this all by myself the
entire time I'd rather watch Kevin Hart
standup it'll be more evenly balanced
and it won't be so irritated I walked
out of this movie feeling like I did
when I walked out a cop-out which means
if you like cop-out [ __ ] you might like
this movie I didn't dig cop out I didn't
dig ride-along I'm just gonna say you're
not gonna remember this movie in t-minus
a couple hours it already forgot welcome
back January we all missed you for about
two days right so right along have you
seen it what did you think about it do
you think Kevin Hart's funny I think I
just want to know if it's an anomaly in
my head whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]